[Music]
okay our final speaker many of you know
him he doesn't really need much of an
introduction but I'll just briefly tell
you what he's been doing recently he has
been to pag Baghdad and to Kuwait
recently on a mission to free American
and French English hostages
he's met with Saddam Hussein for six
hours
he's also met with the Foreign Minister
Tariq Aziz after the August 2nd invasion
he was the first person to go to Kuwait
and get out American hostages from that
occupation
yes he has been spending a good amount
of his time trying to facilitate a
peaceful settlement by trying to get
both sides of this dispute to sit down
he participated in civil rights
activities in his childhood and in fact
he did participate in the Selma to
Montgomery March I found out he was only
a small child commitment at an early age
he is currently the senator from the
besieged state of Washington DC I don't
know if people know that right now he is
waging a heroic battle to finally get
the people of Washington DC many of whom
were people of color to actually have a
say in the governance over themselves
they do not have representation in the
House or the Senate
and he would hope that as many people as
possible can contribute to that effort
and make him become the legitimate
senator he should be representing more
people than senators in five different
states so let's hope that Jesse Jackson
is the next senator of Washington DC
[Applause]
okay I did not want to get into a long
thing about Reverend Jackson the senator
from Washington
he he has a long history and not only
civil rights issues of racial justice
but he has been perhaps the leading
national spokesperson of supportive
grassroots organizations unions women's
groups you name it he has been there for
poor people and I think we're really
honored to have the Reverend Jesse
Jackson speak to us now
[Applause]
let me express to you tonight my sincere
appreciation the organizers of this
event allowing me to participate in this
historic event which could literally
save the whole world tonight you are at
the center of the universe and can
determine its course by tilting the axis
toward peace and away from war
I won't announce that this week mit is
inaugurating the MIT peace and justice
center you'll be called upon to John in
efforts for peace there'll be a whole
week of activities where there will be
organizing and the education of people
against war in the Gulf pursuing
alternatives to war tonight that would
be the inauguration of the peace and
justice center immediately upon the
conclusion of this program we urge you
tonight when we will then finish to
march with us to the building next door
that the whole nation might see and
other campuses might grasp your spirit
and make centers for peace and justice
on every campus around this nation yes
around this world you are to be
congratulated
to those of you who are in here tonight
and the thousands of others who are
connected around this campus your
concern and your sense of desperation is
a contagious spirit they must grip our
nation and our world but you must
congratulate senators Canada and Corey
Kerry for their vote on this past
Saturday
when we think of dr. Martin Luther King
jr. tonight is the eve of his 62nd
birthday tomorrow should be a day for
worldwide celebration of the birth date
of the apostle of non-violence and peace
not the day for showdown the world war
probably hold our breath bated breath
overall peace peace and justice by
indivisible as we pursue this quest to
change our nation's political mindset as
are painfully reflect upon devoting this
past Saturday we launched the vote in
the Senate by the margin of defected
Democrats one Republican Party is enough
sanctions are working what's the rush
for the other official date January the
15th
there was no cutoff date to end
apartheid in South Africa
we have restrictions on South Africa and
sanctions on Iraq and even those weak
restrictions imposed by our Congress
call sanctions or being circumvented by
President Bush we're importing South
African iron and steel into our country
we do not need it American iron and
steel workers are unemployed in South
Africa does not deserve the market and
yet there is no cutoff date Corrin
Nelson Mandela might have the right to
vote January the 15th we're not about to
be attacked on tomorrow the vital
resources to America are not about to be
cut off on tomorrow it's an artificial
date with destiny driven by ego needs
and political needs not national
security needs
the artificial date reflects not
national threat but anxiety about the
fragility of this business alliance
called a worldwide coalition if we truly
support UN resolutions which is a new
idea for this administration
mr. Reagan mr. Bush would not pay UN
dues in the 1980s they tried to impose
sanctions on the UN if we support the UN
let's pay them the 600 million dollars
that we owe them in back dues so the UN
can be used in liberia and other nations
around the world where it is needed the
UN has not imposed these sanctions
there has been no vote before the United
Nations 26 nations in the UN voted China
which represents one-fourth of the human
race did not vote the Japanese offer
some yen the German some marks but no
people others in it because of debt
forgiveness or more weapons or grants or
intimidation it's not that we fear
attack from Iraq tomorrow we fear the
the fragile business alliance been a
hole that we stripped from the
terrorists to offense
dr. Martin Luther King jr. his legacy is
a call to action
it called to leadership to not follow
opinion polls but the mold opinion
bennett to cause us to popularity
politics calls us to expediency but
rather to cause us to do the right thing
bold leadership new direction and action
the issue in the Middle East tonight
should be the goal to get Iraq out of
Kuwait not the date the focus must be
the goal not the date the bombing would
kill thousands of Kuwaitis Iraqis and
Americans it would invite royal
seduction into war the bombs fall on on
the Iraqis if they hit are here at
Israel it will respond in its interests
the noose worth must fly over Jordan and
Syria they will respond the war will not
just be fought in the Middle East the
expressions I've been economically and
militarily will be felt around the whole
world with discussing a world war not a
limited strategic war a limited surgical
war we could not employ surgical war
against Panama and they didn't have an
Air Force
and with also believe in surgical
bombing let them hold the building let
them and their children hold the
building while Obama takes the building
away and leave them standing those who
believe in surgical wars and hits if we
win the bombing war within must remain
and an occupy that which we bomb we must
then occupy Kuwait and Iran as we're now
doing Panama if the war takes place the
price of oil will go up the price of
blood will go down the many will die the
few will prosper worldwide economic
inflation governments would be
destabilized terror will strike the
world
MIT do the world a favor don't just
protest war make war less likely by
committing yourself to study War no more
in the final analysis we do what we
study that's why the ancient proper eyes
there urged us centuries ago to study
War no more and beat our swords into
plowshares make our weapons of war
become weapons of development swords and
apply shares spears into pruning hooks
Isaiah talked about conversion war build
up the peace build up thousands of years
ago even then they recognized the
futility of war war represents moral
exhaustion intellectual bankruptcy when
there's no thoughts left when there is
no hope left we fight to reflect our
emptiness and our lack of vision
if you started teaching you may not have
a job in school but whenever you go down
the street and see children going to at
school lesson plans come on your mind
you kind of do what you study if you
study law
you may choose not to be a practicing
lawyer but wherever you see a judge
wrappers gavel the sense of law that
you've studied begins to come out
somehow you want to do what you studied
if you started music you may not be a
practicing musician but every time you
hear the sound criticisms come in your
mind if you study medicine you may not
be a practicing physician with whenever
you pass a hospital or whenever you hear
the sound of a molasses and whenever you
see blood in the where that is a pool to
do what you studied it so if you study
war and use your mind your brilliant
scientific minds to make these weapons
then you lay the basis for the use of
them we must have the moral judgment the
good sense to study War no more and beat
our swords in the process
greatest threat to our environment
tonight is nuclear weapons
well there's understandable concern
amount so though our musain may get a
nuclear weapon there 300 the phone and
nuclear weapons already in the Persian
Gulf tonight and plan a is to strike and
strike quickly with awesome power if
plan a fails and there's a counter
strike what is Plan B when we lose a war
when we accept heavy casualties without
using Plan B we are close to a nuclear
war Archean by an artificial date with
destiny
dr. King's birthday maybe his vision his
prophecy will be the saving grace the
redemption of our nation and the
salvation of our world tonight
I remember along with a group of staff
members being with him on his last
birthday we did not know it would be his
last birthday January 15 1968 we are not
realized that April 4th 1968 would be
his death date his last date on earth
was spent focusing on organizing
unorganized workers economic justice for
the least of these social justice for
everybody
don't let birth date our amendment so
well that morning he has breakfast at
home with his nuclear family his wife
and children he came to church around 10
o'clock and his work clothes that we had
with us a small group of whites and
Hispanics and Native Americans and
people with whom with never worked
before with whom but never worked before
organizing a Poor People's Campaign he
knew a way to end racial tensions was to
raise up the use of economic justice to
make everybody secure he was organizing
the Poor People's Campaign preparing for
another march on Washington we spent
that morning as you honor dr. King and
as you celebrate his birthday here's how
he spent his her own birthday with
family
at church organizing a national campaign
for a job on income for everybody
reviving the world poverty another war
on the poor a friend came in around one
o'clock with a cake we stopped with
candles we laughed we ate the cake and
then around 2:30 a workshop on ways to
end the war in Vietnam they focus on how
to end the war the study of war and
change national priorities and thus in
world peace he split his own last
birthday family war on poverty and rural
peace you can do no less tomorrow and
the focus on racial justice social
justice and peace
because justice and peace are
indivisible it can't have a peace
movement to save awesome war in the
Persian Gulf and ignore the lack of
racial justice the Djinn Explorer tation
this taking place at home dr. mom that
the King jr. had a broader focus than
that we must be concerned tonight
infant mortality for african-american
babies is locking on to Bangladesh an
impoverished third world country and
black adults died seven years earlier
than whites lives of stress
the incarceration for young
african-american males is four times
greater than that of South Africa the
person with their Beto a civil rights
bill in 1919 using race as bait
within the reality that Beto was against
women and workers physically disabled
Hispanics and blacks as well that the
result of lack of life options on the
one hand the jails are full the other
hand the third there were some of the
ground troops in Persian Gulf for
African American for the five percent
black and brown seventy five percent
black brown and poor those who made the
judgment on Saturday have no children
and because of lack of racial justice if
the war breaks out the black and the
brown the pool will burn first in the
Gulf and their Paris will freeze first
because of economic inflation at home
some Republican senator said to me on
Saturday as I've talked with him about
DC statehood gesture now you know I'm
not for quarters it's a hard sell and
the fact that you get VC stealers you're
probably have two Democratic senators
and maybe of that was some chance of one
Democrat one Republican it may be more
plausible I said are you suggesting that
we have fifty percent Democrats and
fifty percent Republicans in the Persian
Gulf are you saying we've got to bring
the poor to him in the black two minute
round in the Persian Gulf if I used I'm
not there based upon their political
party then why impose that rule in our
quest for self-determination at home
racial justice because of the real sense
unless we're in slavery for blacks we
cannot speak of a suffragette movement
for women in some real sense the quest
for justice and peace are indivisible
racial justice
it tears up our coalition at home that's
needed for the peace movement five world
Jessa hams that she used the shakin
white hand theory quite hand about
together job chicken and ass is about to
get the job the strong black hand pushed
it back if that strong black hand have a
basketball in it its name was Michael
Jordan it's alright if that strong black
hand had a football in it and its name
was bull Jackson it would be all right
if that strong black hand other rifle in
it pointing at the Iraq it's alright but
if it's trying to go to college to get a
job
it seems the national threat
the fact is our jobs we lost three
million jobs in Maine is 800,000 family
farmers they did not go from white to
black they did not go from male to
female we should not have racist
threaten and fighting each other and I
can't process we should not have men
threatened by women and whites by blacks
and browns we should be expanding our
options and not fighting each other
what did the jobs go they didn't go to
abandon the urban ghettos and Barrios
the shoe industry from north from the
north from the New England area which is
the Far East not to the ghetto the Nike
tennis shoes that Michael Jordan wears
the Reebok you see their leg issues are
made in Taiwan in South Korea for $10 a
pair and so therefore 160 they didn't go
from white to black the DCR s that we
use didn't go for white the black down
no American made the VCR s the Venus
beneath electronic jobs the wind Chicago
didn't go from white the black they went
to Mexico cheap labor undercutting
organized labor the bad law
american-made bicycles swing bicycles
are made in Taiwan give me my friend
these hundred thousand family farmers
did not lose their farms the black
surrounds the contact with Cargill the
Agra Giants consume them the little dog
that uses listen to his master's voice
the RCA amplifier that little dog is
gone now the english-speaking trained
dog the master now speaks Dutch and
German and Japanese that dog left and so
did those jobs and I might add the dust
the German Japanese they did not take
our market we sold it in a trade off we
chose to make we said
there's no basis for Asian fashion the
Japanese did not take our jobs the
Germans the desk did not take them
we made a macho trade-off you are not
allowed to make missiles and b-1 bombers
the big stuff you make little stuff like
chips
VCRs on the Toyota Saturn you make me
look stuff that everybody needs we make
big old stuff of which there's no
consumer market and so now we got
weapons that nobody wants and they're
making products that they can not make
enough of we must stand for racial
justice but don't stop there social
justice in this coalition for they mean
Americans with no health insurance
[Music]
people dying in the emergency rooms cuz
they don't have a green or yellow card
to go upstairs good minds good minds
can't go to college in the world's
richest country social justice when the
economic crisis not because the poor
want jobs and women want equality the
S&L crisis six hundred billion dollars
of legal thievery they open the vault
and then five the gods and there are
bacon crises and then an insurance
crisis that must be a commitment to
economic justice and fairness greed not
the poor winning the work is the source
of our economic crisis
[Applause]
social justice a commitment to rebuild
America make all of us better and not
bitter and more secure social justice
peace
I was in the Middle East about three
months ago
it's clear to me we should stand for the
restoration of Kuwaitis sovereignty the
cybersecurity for resolution the Iraq
Kuwait a conflict we could not stand
idly by while the strong devour the weak
ok military deterrence is working but
you're gonna apply those first of all in
new world order apply them to Kuwait
West Bank Lebanon Lithuania Nicaragua El
Salvador Grenada Panama Angola South
Africa apply those principles around the
world
we lose our moral authority selectively
applying those principles what about the
blood in Kinnaman square what about the
crushing of Lithuanian what about
apartheid in South Africa play the game
of the New World Order by one set of
rules and regain our moral authority in
this world
what about the cost of this war
administration officials estimate the
cause of person gulf deployment
we're range twenty five to thirty
billion dollars for fiscal year 1991
just to transport and maintain us
equipment and personnel which is
expected to soon reach four hundred and
ten thousand the Center for Defense
Information estimation and it come at
erupts the cost of war would exceed a
hundred and sixty three billion dollars
for 1991 four hundred and fifty million
dollars per day nineteen million dollars
every hour the Bush administration
Frisky in 1991 budget for human capital
programs including education and job
programs for the one point four billion
down from forty five billion in 1988 the
church was the first fall an estimated
in 1988 the cost be limiting poverty in
families with children would have been
twenty six billion today fifty four
billion a fraction of the cost of a
shooting war he estimated eighty two
million dollars per day it will cost to
transport feet and maintain the Persian
Gulf troops is nearly twenty times the
cost the children offense spawn proposed
the US Student Association estimates
that the daily cost of Operation Desert
Shield could give federal grants to
fifty nine thousand six hundred fifty
five students or Schrader nine thousand
towards and twenty students call his
work-study jobs both programs have been
cut over the past decade there is a way
out
and we need guided Minds not miss guided
missiles there is the way out where to
have peace when we condemn the invades
them kuwait we're right we second I'm
extensions they're working we're right I
was there
he cannot expand me on Kuwait he has the
hotels but no customers the oil wells
but no markets all I cannot get in or
cannot get out he can't grow sanctions
aren't working there are three articles
in the UN resolution we focused on two
article one condemned the invasion of
Kuwait alkyl to unconditional withdrawal
are the three resolve the Kuwaiti Iraq a
disputed let's focus for a minute on the
zone of dispute unconditional withdrawal
does not mean ignore the zone of dispute
that was a dispute prior to the invasion
the invasion and next section occupation
was wrong way to resolve the dispute
that was a recognized dispute recognized
by the US Kuwait and the UN it had to do
with all pricing or gouging land
boundaries and access to the sea why
can't we be creative enough to agree to
mutually no bombing during negotiations
and after there'll be a fair credible
court World Court Arab Court you in
court to adjudicate the issues in
dispute and proceed with international
peace conference and why should that be
for us so confusing we're not talking
about the hue saying peace conference
we're done with the un-sponsored
International Peace Conference
it predates August 2nd to ignore the
Peace Conference is is reversed linkage
it's saying in effect unless we end the
occupation in Kuwait we will not proceed
with peace what about that in vision and
the gates proceeding with peace for the
region that's nothing that there's a
Middle East crisis
I wish the Iraqi invasion of Kuwait is a
dimension of it a commitment to no
bombing and commitments in the gold
shade in the zone of dispute and
commitment an international peace
conference well mr. Anand Europe are
already there the world is searching for
a way a way out the fact is the ground
attack the ante attack will not save
Kuwait there are thousands of Kuwait is
who remain in Kuwait and all out and
attack will kill thousands of Kuwaitis
to save them
if we bomb Kuwait and and Iraq and if we
win within must stay there while they
redevelop stay there in Iran as we have
had to do in Panama
suppose we win being occupation then
global animosity being unlimited cost if
we attack Iraq and they shoot a shoot at
Israel they must respond to do so they
must fly over Jordan and Syria if they
become directly involved
Mubarak cannot restrain the feelings of
the Egyptians if the wall strikes in the
Persian Gulf will feel the impact
economically and militarily within our
own country why risk a world war using
overkill and misguided missiles when we
have the use of God in minds and our
disposal I'm sincerely convinced sticken
Kuwait's sovereignty beginning is the
right thing to do but my friends as we
fight for self-determination in Kuwait
this great pressable self-determination
well I'm your senator from Washington
i sat in the balcony of the Senate on
this past Saturday watching us fight for
the self-determination of 200,000 Kuwait
is and and 600,000 residents of
Washington cannot vote
there are more troops in the Persian
Gulf reserves from Washington than 18
States more per capita than for the
eight states if our service do not go to
the Persian Gulf they go to jail going
to fight for principles in the Middle
East they did they're denied at home as
I said they're watching that debate more
people live in Washington than Vermont
Delaware North Dakota Wyoming and Alaska
I watched ten senators vote who
represent fewer people than I do in
Washington we pay more taxes than ten
states which they have 20 US senators
make your vote and and we could not in
the name of self-determination the faith
occupier fifty percent of the city and
the diplomat it's tax-exempt 60 percent
of the income is cannot be taxed at the
source and so we subsidize the feds and
we subsidize the suburbs
self-determination though we have a
right to vote and South Africa you can
you can vote in Soweto for your local
officials to administer Soweto but they
can't vote in Pretoria in Washington we
can vote for local officials we can't
vote on Capitol Hill it's the same basic
principle of colonialism we want the
principles of self-determination applied
all over the world yes beginning at home
and so I say to young America tonight
what made Martin King different was a
will to act while he studied on the
campus is in this area he was in the
middle of many analysts and there's a
danger getting the paralysis of analysis
and never act and make things happen
it's time to act the whole world at
stake it's time to act a call to action
a call to hope don't surrender to war we
must not be morally bankrupt
we march too long we've been jailed too
much we die too young
we've seen the futility at war you could
be looking at your final exam unless we
choose peace over war and negotiation
over confrontation I heard you tonight
to study well no more beat your swords
into plowshares your spirits are the
pruning hooks let's turn to each other
and not only Chavo let's love and
respect each other justice
for the Kuwaitis security for the south
is coexistence which renders and
Palestinians rather than toward
annihilation freedom in South Africa
peace and el salvador and nicaragua into
the bloodshed in liberia no more war in
Angola democracy in China in the killing
in Little India let's make the whole
world more secure and let's be better
and not bitter and be driven by
suffering and serving and sacrificing
that which is good and right rise above
racism and sexism and anti-semitism and
anti-arab ISM and Asian fashion this is
the generation that the Lord have called
to choose this day save the world
literally five children and our
posterity let no street miss the
pitter-patter of our marching feet let
no school miss our powerful discourse
but every politician we all know this do
we choose life over there and through it
all and it will be tough keep hope alive
don't give up
keep hope alive No Surrender keep hope
alive
study War no more keep hope alive save
the children keep hope alive stop the
bombing keep hope alive
which is our world teeth hope alive
teeth hope alive teeth
[Applause]
t.t hope alive teeth hope alive
keep hope alive t letter more determined
[Music]
[Applause]